the jurogan experience well well well
it is an old horse worm rogan
i'm glad you're i'm glad you're well man
bro do i have to sue cnn i don't know i
don't know do you they're making [ __ ] up
they keep saying i'm taking horse
dewormer i literally got it from a
doctor
it's an american company
it's a
they won the nobel prize in 2015 for use
in human beings yeah and
cnn is saying i'm taking horse dewormer
yeah what so they must know that that's
a lie there's a lot of people saying it
right but a lot of people can say it
okay like the internet says i do care
sure but cnn is saying it like jim
acosta i meant like like usa today a few
other play yeah and they're talking
about about ivermectin yeah so what
because i don't know i just saw
so much news yeah about you i mean i
would talk to you and check on you and
see if you're all right and you're like
you you threw the kitchen sink at it you
said which was stuff that you know you
took
iv drips and was it mono what mono
monoclonal antibodies and that what is
monoclonal antibodies the [ __ ] they gave
trump okay yeah and then what so who
said or did you already want ivermectin
like well i have this guy on dr pierre
corey and he is what is the organization
he's from frontline
covid critical care workers
he's uh
well-established doctors treated
thousands of people with covet and
they've uh the early on the pandemic
they
found some
good uh efficacy with uh
with with um ivermectin
frontline 19 critical care
alliance okay
yeah
um
so i had him on and you know he had
talked to me about it's not he's not the
only doctor that told me to take it
multiple doctors told me to take it
it's uh it's supposed to have uh what is
the exact
thing it's supposed to do there's
there's something that i highlighted
um
and this is obviously i'm not a doctor
it says ivermectin was found to be a
blocker
of viral
uh replica replicase
r-e-p-l-i-c-a-s-a proteas and i don't
know what this word is
human t-m-p-r-s-s-2
i don't know but what they didn't
highlight is that i got better yeah you
got better questions try to make it seem
as if like
i'm doing some wacky [ __ ] that's
completely ineffective right cnn was
saying that i'm a distributor of
misinformation also that was the other
thing that happened
the um
in tokyo in japan which is apparently
uh they're very conservative about the
medication that they they use and the
medications that they
endorse but the tokyo medical
association chairman held a live press
conference recommending ivermectin to
all doctors for all covet patients
so what's going on with the like the you
know it's kind of hard to to figure out
what's
the truth in a lot of things but with
regard to this people go
it's insane to take ivermectin like you
see it everywhere everyone's like this
is wow don't take this [ __ ] and then you
have the head of the [ __ ]
tokyo whatever medical commission saying
take eyebrows i don't know what's going
on man you know there's a lot of
speculation one of the speculations
involves the
emergency use authorization for the
vaccines
that in order for there to be an
emergency use authorization there has to
be no treatment
for a disease right so
because there is
this treatment in in ivermectin and
there's other treatments too right
um because of this there's a lot of
pushback against
potential treatments and pretending that
they don't really work or that they're
conspiracy theories this is the this is
the grand conspiracy right the grand
conspiracy is the pharmaceutical
companies are all in cahoots to try to
make anybody who takes the stuff look
crazy but what's crazy is look how
bitter i got yeah i got better pretty
quick [ __ ] let's go to like your your
whole experience so you get back from a
trip right and
is it that night do you arrive home and
no or like on your way home you're like
i don't feel so great um
well saturday here's what happened
friday night we went out and got
hammered mm-hmm went out and played pool
until 3 30 in the morning had a bunch of
drinks
had a bright bunch of drinks at the show
at the show i think i had two drinks and
then i had like four afterwards so yeah
we're pretty lit yeah and it was 3 30 in
the morning exhausted playing travel you
know flew that day from um
i guess so fort lauderdale was the first
show then that was tampa and then last
show was orlando um
that night i just i was worn out
friday night you know because 3 30 in
the morning and i was like yeah i got to
crash
and then i woke up in the morning and i
was definitely hungover
but i was also just feeling a little out
of it just a little just a little
just not good it's hard to describe
if i had kovit it was just like
beginning stages
but i thought it was a hangover right
which kind of confuses you
how you can read it so drink a lot of
water um ate took a bunch of vitamins
went to sleep got up for the show felt
good
um no drinks that night
um
and then that night we flew back
and so
just feeling worn out you know pretty
normal but worn out
and then when i got home i was like man
something just feels off so i told my
wife you know you should probably um
keep away from me let me isolate lucky
we have a big house isolated and in the
middle of the night i was sweating you
know i would get fevers and i just i
wasn't feeling good and you knew it then
i woke up in the morning i knew it in
the morning by time the morning i was
like something's going on
let's see what it is 90 whatever percent
sure it was coveted so
morning i got tested
turn out positive and then this is
sunday sunday so sunday sunday you find
out you're positive and then
that day you bet you feel sick right
you're just in bed relaxing yeah that's
a headache
sick do you do you immediately this is
what i didn't hadn't asked you yet had
you did you have a plan in place in your
head for like if i get covered i would
do these so you yeah so when you find
out you're positive yeah you start
reaching out for
these
treatments yeah i already have i already
have it in place you did yeah i was
already ready to go so and then you
started taking them that day
yeah i got it i got all the stuff that i
needed took it that day
and then monday i felt pretty [ __ ]
good and i was taking vitamin iv drips
every day high dose vitamin c
vitamin d
and nad as well my concern when i spoke
to you was just will you please [ __ ]
rest
that's what i texted you i was like no
hill runs no [ __ ] kettlebells and
don't wrestle any [ __ ] cattle today
just
rest i feel like i'm going to rest i'm
going to i rested i know i did i rested
i did i didn't do [ __ ] but watch tv i
actually enjoyed the first couple days
because i was like this is a nice like a
legit solid excuse where i don't have to
do anything yes which never comes up
right that was like when the pandemic
started back in
march last year where it was like no you
have to cancel your dates i was like it
would be like a nice week off
sure two weeks to slow the spread yeah
let's [ __ ] chill out yeah yeah um so
but you know after i did this and i i
hit it with the nad
and the uh high dose vitamin c i think
it was ten thousand ten thousand
milligrams of vitamin c in the iv drip
which is like very
it's very effective it goes right into
your bloodstream right yeah
um
after that and the monoclonal antibodies
and all the other stuff
literally on monday i felt pretty
[ __ ] good that's yeah so that's
pretty
pretty fast pretty fast yeah mine when i
got covered i was in
like the hospital
recovering from surgery right
and i thought it was
uh
the opioid withdrawals
of which they told me that you're gonna
feel like [ __ ] when you get off of these
like the flu right yeah it's exactly
they said you're gonna get emotional and
you're gonna feel terrible and i was
like okay and i got off of them like on
a saturday
i stopped taking them after like two
weeks
and then on
monday
i think it was monday or tuesday i had
pt and ot back to back and afterwards i
was like man i feel terrible what is ot
occupational therapy
above the waist is kind of the way they
tell you like pts below the waist ots
above the waist so they were treating my
knee for pt and then the ot was like the
arm and hand stuff
and i did them back to back like another
hour each and i'm all [ __ ] up so
they're like yeah of course you're tired
and [ __ ] like take a nap i slept like
three hours and they're like god damn
and i
and here's the thing no it occurred to
nobody that i had covet the next day i'm
like i have diarrhea
my my shoulders like my traps neck so
achy i was like oh and they're like yeah
he's just [ __ ] worn out from the
therapy and getting off of the opiates
and everything and
and then the the next day a little
better but still shitty
and the third day i was like i feel
better you know and the fourth day i was
like i feel fine so that was kind of
like my window and it was the last the
fourth day where they were like do you
wanna take a cover test i was like for
what they're like oh for when you felt
like [ __ ] three days ago and i go yeah
okay and so i took the coveted test
and my favorite is that they're like uh
do you want same-day results and i go
yeah and they go it's expensive and i go
this [ __ ] hospital stays expensive
what are you talking about like right
this is thousands of dollars a day you
think i i don't want to spend a hundred
dollars more to find out today
so
i said yeah let's do same day and then
they tested at the end of the day i go
where's my result
and they're like we don't know
so the next day i'm going home
and it's it's it's a saturday
and they're taking me home and i was
like hey whatever happened to my [ __ ]
covet test
and now i feel like totally fine
and they go uh i don't know i'm gonna
call the lady that took the test and i
was like what the [ __ ]
so crazy so i get home i watch a movie
with my kids
and the email goes ding and i open it
and it says positive
that's how i found out so you're [ __ ]
super protected yes
because
they showed up there was a study that
showed that if you've had a previous
covet infection you're six to 13 times
more protected than you are with just a
pfizer
yeah i try
you know i gave up the argument i was
arguing with my cousin who's an id
doctor
what's an id doctor infectious disease
doctor so this is what she treats she's
in the hospitals you know every day and
uh
she was like when the delta variant came
out she was like this thing is no joke
she's like this is all i'm seeing you
have to get back especially if you're
going on tour i was like
i was like well what about whatever i
was like fine i'll just go
yeah well it didn't bother you yeah it
didn't bother me
i'm still um
doing that um like i'll still [ __ ]
hook up a little green [ __ ] yeah here
and there what a week out
uh a week yesterday yeah yeah
yeah it's not that long but it doesn't
feel bad yeah like
great workout workout today yeah i had a
great workout today felt great
that's my second workout i had one
workout two days three days ago three
days ago um then took yesterday off and
then worked out again today yeah no
problem at all just feel completely
normal great yeah and your breathing's
fine yeah except the the hawking up
little yeah but they're little ones how
crazy
maybe you're immune to it now from
having
so much public scrutiny but like
having people wish you got sicker isn't
that crazy i didn't pay attention it's
crazy to me i mean i've had people you
know wish
harm on me and threaten me and tell me
they wish i was dead and all this stuff
but fun yeah you're like cool man uh
thanks for watching this special um but
it's like
when you're sick yeah people are like i
wish you were more sick well the good
news is i was only sick for a day that's
true
it's just it's just wild that there's
people they're like i wish you were more
sick
i wish well i wish you were in the
hospital because i wasn't scared during
the entire pandemic what they would like
is that when i did get sick
that i was really sick you let me became
really scared and learn my lesson and
instead it's the worst case scenario for
them right i bounce back
about as quick as you [ __ ] can yeah
and they're haters yeah but that's their
life
you got to live like that imagine
spending any time whatsoever wishing
that a person felt bad yeah it's the
dumbest [ __ ] thing you could ever
spend your energy on yeah and it doesn't
work
you can't it doesn't it doesn't make
people feel worse like god i wish so
hard and he's okay
so crazy i i you know i'd heard that
that was going on but i didn't pay
attention to it it's like you know
they're weak [ __ ] yeah you stay salty
yeah
we're doing all right
everything's fine yeah i'm doing pretty
good but meanwhile i don't have a bad
message my message is be healthy and
obviously there's some merit to that
you know and merit to being consistently
healthy
you know the end
here's a message the the thing that
[ __ ] me is drinking
i think that really [ __ ] me yeah i bet
if i went home early went to the hotel
early friday night and got sleep like i
normally do i better would have never
got me
you think so yeah i was hammered we're
out playing pool till like i said 3 30
in the morning
i mean you know i love playing pool so
yeah i'll play pool till i'm [ __ ]
exhausted oh my god i went on a trip
with you once
dude
it was like
stand up to pool
to the whole next day like you're like i
didn't go to bed
you got back at like 9 00 a.m and then
we went out to breakfast and i was like
what are you talking about
you're fine i was like
no way dude well you know that that
message is not a good message no the up
all night message and the drinking
message is that yeah my messages don't
do that and it is stupid and i haven't
had a drink since then watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify